Today, the job of building this nation geographically is completed.
There are no new frontiers within our borders.
So, to what new horizons can we look now?
Where are tomorrow's opportunities?
What's ahead for you? For your children?
The frontiers of the future are not on any man.
They are in the test tubes and laboratories of the great industries.
The Chakrabarty case is one of the great judicial moments in world history.
And the public was totally unaware it was actually happening as the process was being engaged.
General Electric and a Professor Chakrabarty went to the patent office with a little microbe that eats up oil spills.
They said they had modified this microbe in the laboratory and therefore it was an invention.
The patent office of the US government took a look at this "invention" and they said, "No way."
The patent statutes don't cover living things.
This is not an invention; turned down.
Then, General Electric and Dr. Chakrabarty appealed to the US Customs Court of Appeal.
And to everyone's surprise by a three - to - two decision, they overwrote the patent office.
And they said this microbe looks more like a detergent or reagent than a horse or a honey bee.
I laughed because they didn't understand basic biology.
It looked like a chemical to them.
Had it had an antenna or eyes, and wings, or legs; it would never have crossed their table and been patented.
Then the patent office appealed.
And what the public should realize now is the patent office was very clear that you can't patent life.
My organization provided the main amicus curiae brief.
"If you allow the patent on this microbe," we argued,...
"...it means that without any congressional guidance or public discussion,..."
"...corporations will own the blueprints of life."
When they made the decision, we lost by five - to - four and Chief Justice Warren Burger said,...
"Sure, some of these are big issues but we think this is a small decision."
Seven years later, the US patent office issued a one - sentence decree,...
"You can patent anything in the world that's alive, except a full - birthed human being."